this is starting to sort of get
repetitive but I think it's still really
important to do we have a cycle that has
become very common in modern American
politics the president makes a
completely unrealistic promise he then
fails to deliver on that promise then he
brags about the results even though they
fall short of his promise then we find
out he criticized a Democratic operative
a politician or prior president for the
exact same result
this time it's Barack Obama over the GDP
and Donald Trump's prediction of for
five or even six percent GDP growth let
me set it up for you and we'll get right
into it
GDP is the gross domestic product it's
one of the main ways that we measure the
size of our economy there's a lot of
debate over whether GDP is the right way
to evaluate an economy but putting that
aside for now
this is the total value of all the stuff
we produce in the services that we
provide in a year that's our GDP during
his campaign and after becoming
president Donald Trump was talking about
we're gonna have three percent GDP
growth four percent GDP growth five even
six percent GDP growth here's just one
example of Donald Trump doing this this
one's during his presidency he's been
predicting it since he was just
candidate Trump but to get it going the
way I really want where we have GPP
getting up to four or five and even six
percent because I think that's possible
if you look back in your notes you'll
say when I say four percent people said
that would be years well it's turned out
that I'm right because without the
hurricanes this last quarter we would
have hit four percent so of course none
of this has happened and yesterday we
learned that in the third quarter of
this year the GDP was just 1.9 percent
now just it's actually pretty normal
that's a relatively normal level of GDP
growth it's not particularly good or
particularly bad but the thing is Donald
Trump is now cheering it as if it is a
signal of the best economy ever
literally tweeting yesterday quote the
greatest economy in American history
but back in 2012 when Barack Obama had
the exact same 1.9 percent GDP growth
what did Donald Trump tweet because
there's a tweet for everything Donald
Trump tweeted cue
GDP has just been revised down to 1.9
percent the economy is in deep trouble
and of course it wasn't but if it was
then Trump's economy must likewise be in
deep trouble on the basis of those same
GDP numbers so this is one more of
Donald Trump's insane predictions and
his distortions and his being the pot
that calls the kettle black but this is
also economically disastrous and I'm
going to tell you why remember Donald
Trump when he told us about his tax cut
plan was told that's gonna blow up the
deficit it doesn't balance it's gonna
explode the deficit and Donald Trump
said no no no this tax cut plan is going
to cause such growth we're going to
cause you know 3% 4% 5% 6% GDP growth
that the growth will pay for the tax
cuts in a way that none of the analysts
are coming clean with you about the
proposal for tax cuts was scored and it
was a trainwreck totally underwater
hugely deficit exploding but his
acolytes repeated this claim they said
the estimates are wrong GDP will be up
up up 5 6 % it'll pay for the tax cuts
in total now aside from whether that
makes sense at all and I would argue it
doesn't it's what he claimed and it is
not happening and his followers are
falling for it we were told the GDP will
go up so much that the tax cuts will be
paid for and everything is going to be
so good everybody will win ever it's
just winning for everybody and instead
the opposite has happened and we are now
curating or maybe there's a better way
of saying it Trump ISM is curating one
of the lowest Information electorates
that actually thrives on Trump lies and
is energized by the distortions which
they can then go and repeat all over the
internet and Twitter and the normal
enclaves applying no critical analysis
whatsoever either because they're
choosing not to apply any critical
analysis or because they lack the
intellectual capacity and knowledge of
critical thinking and epistemology that
might be required to do that analysis of
what Donald Trump is telling them but it
is hugely damaging to the economy
it's hugely damaging to the fabric of
the country in terms of just basic
intellectual rigor and thinking and it
has opened the door for this to become
the absolute new normal in future
presidencies in future campaigns where
promises don't matter any failed promise
by the person on your quote team is
either because someone is miss stating
what the promise was or because of the
other party that got in the way or
because of it it doesn't even matter
what it is will excuse it saying in some
way shape or form the left does this to
some degree it's not as bad but I don't
want to do it and if you see me doing it
then I hope you will call me out for
applying a different standard to the
left than the right one of my priorities
and I think I'm doing an okay job of it
is when the same criticism could apply
to both parties I apply it to both
parties when there are differences
between the parties I point out what
they are and when the status quo is
either implicitly or explicitly
reinforced by both parties because it's
more of an establishment versus
anti-establishment thing I hope that I'm
pointing that out to you as well if I'm
if I'm falling short of that goal I do
want you to let me know